Welcome back.
Where I had just left off we
were trying to figure out this
area between these two curves,
and we figured out that it's
really the area between the
curves between the point 0,
x equals 0 and x equals 1.
And I was proposing
of a way to do it.
Let's figure out the entire
area under the square root of
x from 0 to 1, and we can
subtract from that, this
purple area, which is the
area under x squared.
So just based on the last
example we did, we could just
write the indefinite integral,
and I'm not going to rewrite
the fundamental theorem from
calculus, because I think
you know that by now.
Let me do it in a loud color.
Magenta.
So I want to know the
larger area, right.
The area under just
the square root of x.
That's Kind of like
the combined area.
Well that's just from 0 to 1,
the integral of square root of
x, because square root of x
is the green function, dx.
And I want to subtract from
that the area from 0 to 1
what's under x squared.
x squared dx.
And I just want
to make a point.
This could have just been
rewritten this way.
You could just rewrite a new
function, which is the
difference of these two
functions, and it would
have been equivalent.
You could have said this.
This isn't kind of a step of
the problem, but you could
have done it this way.
In fact, some people
start this way.
See those are the same thing
as the integral from 0 to 1
of square root of x
minus x squared dx.
So you could do this two
separate problems, two separate
indefinite integrals, or
you could do it as one
indefinite integral.
Actually that might be even
simpler because when you
evaluate it from 1 to 0 it
simplify things a little bit.
So let's stick with
the second one.
So first of all we just have
to figure out what the
antiderivative of this
inner expression is.
So you haven't seen
square root of x yet.
Do you think you
know how to do it?
Well, I think you do.
Let's say that equals square
root of x is just x to
the 1/2 power, right?
So we just use the same
antiderivative rules
we've always used.
We raise it one more power
so it becomes x to the 3/2.
Right, it was 1/2,
we added 1 to it.
And then we divide by
this new exponent.
So dividing by a fraction
is like multiplying
by its reciprocal.
So it's 2/3 x to the 3/2 and
then minus-- I think the second
term is pretty easy for you--
minus 1/3 x to the third.
That's the antiderivative
of minus x squared, minus
1/3 x to the third.
And we're going to have to
evaluate this thing at 0 and 1
and subtract the difference.
Subtract this expression
evaluated at 0 from this
expression evaluated at 1.
I think I'm running
out of space.
What happens when x equals 1?
1 to the 3/2 is 1.
1 to the third is 1.
So it's 2/3 minus 1/3.
Well that's easy.
It's 1/3.
I just put 1 in for x.
And then when x is equal to 0
what is this expression equal?
Well that's easy too.
That's 0.
So there you go.
1/3 minus 0 or 1/3.
That's kind of neat.
You know I find is this of
exciting because if just my
intuition I was like, oh I have
these two curves, and I mean
they do intersect at the nice
integer number, but you know
what it's probably going to be
some really messy number
of what the areas between
these two curves, right.
Who knows, maybe it'll involve
some you know-- a circle
involves pi, which is this
really messy number, so maybe
all curves have these
kind of messy areas.
But this one it's just one of
those neat things about math.
The area between the square
root of x and x squared is 1/3,
which is a pretty clean number.
Actually let me do one more
problem since I have time.
It's a bit of a trick problem.
I mean, you might actually find
this easy, but let's figure out
the area between f of x
is equal to-- I don't
know, x to the fifth.
I'm going to do
something simple.
Let me draw it actually.
OK, I'm going to
draw the x-axis.
x to the fifth is going
to go up super fast,
something like that.
It's going to go up real fast.
Let's say I wanted to figure
out the areas-- this side's
going to go real fast too--
between that, and instead of
figuring out the area between
x-axis and that, f of x, I want
to figure out the area between
f of x and-- Instead
of figuring out this
bottom area, right?
Like the normal problems we've
done, we would figure out this
type of area, you know,
between two points.
Let's say I want to figure out
the area inside of the curve
where the height here is 32.
So I want to figure out this
area inside the curve.
How do we do that?
Well one way we could do it is
just like we did the last one,
we can figure out some function
that's essentially a line, a
horizontal line that goes
straight across here.
And we'll essentially just
be figuring out the area
between the two functions.
So what's a function that's
a line that just goes
straight at y equals 32?
I think I just gave
you the answer.
Exactly.
Let me stick with
that greenish color.
So we could say g of
x is equal to 32.
It's just a constant function.
It just goes straight across.
And then we need to figure out
what the area is between the
two, so we need to figure out
what are these two points.
So when does x to
the fifth equal 32?
I mean you could solve it
algebraically, you know,
you could say x to
the fifth equals 32.
x is equal to 2, and
actually, you know what?
I made a mistake.
Let's say that this is not
equal to x to the fifth.
Let's say that f of x is
equal to x to the absolute
value of x to the fifth.
Because the mistake, obviously
x to the fifth is not a
parabola looking thing.
x to the fifth goes
negative like this.
But I have committed so much to
this cup shape that I'll make
it the absolute value
of x to the fifth.
So if I say the absolute value
of x to the fifth is equal to
32, I think you see where
I realized my mistake.
But if I say the absolute value
of x to the fifth is 32,
there's two places
where that's true.
It's x is equal to
plus or minus 2.
These are the two points.
I should have done something
with an even exponent so I
could have had this cup shape,
but anyway the absolute
value solved my problem.
So what is this area?
We know it's between negative
2 and 2, so we just set up
the indefinite integral.
It's the indefinite integral
for minus 2 to 2 of the top
function, the top boundary, 32,
minus the bottom boundary.
Well, this will be a little bit
tricky, but minus the absolute
value of x to the fifth dx.
And actually instead of doing
this, I think you could see
that there's symmetry here,
so we could just figure out
this area and multiply by 2.
This problem's a little hairy,
just because I had a bad
choice of initial function.
Not exactly what I wanted,
but we'll work on forward.
So instead of doing that, let's
do the integral from 0 to 2 of
32 minus x to the fifth dx.
And then multiply that by 2.
So what is that?
That's 32x minus x to
the sixth over 6.
And we're going to evaluate it
from 2 and 0 at 64 minus 64/6.
2 to the sixth is 64, and
then 32 times 0 is 0 and the
next is 6, that's 0, so the
answer is 64 minus 64/6.
I'm about to run out of time.
That's just a fraction
problem there.
Oh, and that's half
of it, right?
So we want to
multiply that by 2.
So if we multiply that by
2, we get 128 minus 128/6.
I haven't figured
out what it is.
Well I guess we could
figure it out.
It's 128 times 1 minus
1/6 or 128 times 5/6.
And I don't know what that is.
I can multiply if I wanted to,
but I have 10 seconds left
so I'll leave you there.
Hope I didn't confuse you.
See you soon.